a few months after Johan and I got
married he told me that he opened up a
butcher shop
I assume penis
is this
I am really excited to see his butcher
shop because I'm so proud of him he can
do anything he wants he's six foot seven
and has really big hands he can cut up
some meat sure why not and I am willing
to help him in any way that I can as
long as I don't have to deal with any of
the meat
wow
foreign
I must ask us
I'm like really torn because I don't
want to be like what is this but I also
am like what the [__] is this
[Music]
that can't be good
there's bugs
how do you eat food with bugs on it
okay
do you need meat to be cold I don't know
how to say that in Spanish
that it has bugs on it I'm not going to
buy it
bugs bugs bugs
[Music]
y
come on
contra
[Music]